hey guys justin here at the microsoft
lounge at San Diego Comic Con 2015 I'm
speaking with Kiki wolf gal who works on
the Halo franchise Kiki you put together
a panel today you guys were talking
about the fall of reach the animated
series as well as the companion app that
is coming up for halo well what was the
main crux of the the panel discussion
you guys gave today so the panel was
really focused on halo 5 Guardians story
but really told through about the
campaign story and sort of a lot of the
story pieces that we're doing around it
so a big part of that is halo the fall
of reach the three-part animated series
that we're doing we talked a little bit
about some of our marketing campaigns
and where we introduced a lot of the
different characters in halo 5 but
really the big piece was a halo the fall
of reach is this something that's for
everybody is this something that you see
reaching out to the broader fans or is
this really just for the hardcore now I
think I mean I think we really do want
to bring in sci-fi fans right so I look
at something like halo fall of reach as
for somebody who knows the hail oh Lord
it's like hearing a beloved story and
it's brought to life in a different way
for someone who doesn't right and maybe
it's someone who just plays the game and
really only knows Master Chief is this
sort of armored hero this is his origin
story like this is where you see how he
became a Spartan too and I think it's
just a great sci-fi story so hopefully
we'll reach a little bit of a broader
audience and not just a hardcore halo
fan and I think when you guys describe
the fall of reach isn't and animated
series maybe some people are a little
trepidatious that that's not something
that's gonna be for me is this something
that it's gonna be for all of the fans
how are you guys ensuring that this
isn't just a filler story yeah I mean it
always starts with us in terms of trying
to
make an approachable story with a great
story and it's a great story sequence
who we've worked with before has this
beautiful visual style which i think is
sort of very engaging for anyone and it
sort of has this lyrical and beautiful
concept art it's animated but it is very
accessible and for us you know part of
getting engaged with the universe is
engaging with those stories and those
characters and so we really want as few
barriers as possible to doing that and
since we're here at comic-con I think
one thing people might have been
expecting to hear about though it's a
little surprised we didn't is
Spielberg's project and I was just
wondering maybe how that's coming along
yeah so we're still in development on
the on that Spielberg television series
we're still really excited about it and
that's about all we have to share at
this point
you